moment de détente et de plaisir pour ces
six jeunes filles atteintes de
déficience intellectuelle
la visite d'un institut de beauté va
avoir une personne qui va nous apprendre
à prendre soin de notre peau à devenir
une femme
janick l'esthéticienne leur a fait
découvrir son salon et les a initiés au
maquillage elle aura donné des conseils
de soins
une élue de la ville accompagne le
travail du centre spécialisé qui
s'occupe de ces jeunes adultes
il s'est passé un petit moment de
bonheur mais encore une fois c'est pas
parce que ce sont des gens différents
qu'il faut les traiter différemment ils
ont les mêmes besoins sont les mêmes
dans le centre d'accueil de jour de
saint cyr l'école gérée par
l'association avenir à pays accueille
ainsi une trentaine de jeunes adultes
âgés de 18 à 25 ans qui sont atteints de
déficience intellectuelle légère à
moyenne ils vont être accompagnés dans
ce centre pendant quatre à cinq ans la
mission principale c'est la transition
et c'est de prendre du temps pour savoir
ce que je veux faire parce qu'à 18 ans
19 ans on sait pas encore où on va aller
habiter on sait pas encore quel métier
on veut faire on a besoin de prendre du
temps tout est fait pour développer leur
autonomie dans leur vie quotidienne par
des ateliers des stages des teams de
soin d'hygiène de soin de son corps
comme cette visite aujourd'hui c'est
super j'ai bien aimé dans quelques mois
quelques années elles quitteront le
centre trouveront un métier un logement
comme toutes les autres jeunes filles